and also
and that doesn't go away oh my God all
right guys so we just finished JK news
as you can see we're in the JK new set
but we're gonna start a new series
called our JK news adventures and we're
gonna try to hang out afterwards how
long until it gets canceled huh I don't
know we're just trying different formats
but today because you guys are my close
friends I want to share a special part
of my childhood with you guys which is
Taiwanese food
we're just gonna eat Taiwanese food
let's go dude all right we're gonna get
our asses beat up hey I feel like this
is half true they got chicken nugs
[Applause]
are we gonna [ __ ] ourselves during this
oh dude yeah I feel like there's a
challenge or something like what the
[ __ ] you setting us up for yeah
Gabriel
[Music]
so actually I brought him here because
you know we got to do things JK style
I'm gonna have him eat stinky tofu and
that's really part of Taiwanese like
Cuisine some of them I have eaten it
before some of them may have not but I'm
really interested in their reactions and
there's nothing that brings people
together like food as they say so we'll
see what happens have you ever heard of
Snoopy tofu stinky I've only heard of it
I've only heard of it like it's the
fabled nasty [ __ ] that smells right have
you ever tried it no I thought you're
not supposed to eat it
supposed to eat it you ever heard of
stinky Tucker of course I'm [ __ ]
chinese vietnamese man
shitty ass smell and tofu that I never
really like other people like it it
tastes alright it's not bad why why do
you ask hey you know what I fought some
Taiwanese food I'll say that love the
sweeter Savory versions someone's
cleaners almost oilier you know what I
mean it's almost lighter but it's like
not it's crazy it makes me all fat and
[ __ ] nothing's green hello hi there how
you doing good thank you okay good good
I like your shirt thank you
sparkly
oh thank you hey you know what there's
an orange cone there if you want me to
move it for you I got you all right
yeah it's a stinky tofu what's what are
these interviews about man have you ever
heard of stinky tofu yeah it's tofu that
just smells really bad isn't it
fermented they're fermented is that what
we're eating today and now I'm a little
nervous now really now you're making me
nervous dude like it's gonna be not like
what I'm expecting what were you
expecting well I don't know I didn't
think
because I don't trust Bart dude I don't
trust this guy I know he's setting us up
for something of course I have but you
know what I do off camera eat spicy food
all the [ __ ] time tell chefs give me
the real [ __ ] don't just judge me
because I'm a white guy I go to this
place called Steiners in Vegas if you go
there and you get the hotter Wings
they're really hot they're like actually
spicy and they're delicious I was
talking so much [ __ ] to the waitress I
was like hey can I get some hot sauce on
the side too because like I'm such a
badass and she's like oh so you want
them even more spicy I'm like yeah yeah
and I'm like just I'm just being a
[ __ ] because like it's fine I
shouldn't have said anything that night
I go home Nikki's like hey one [ __ ] I'm
like baby my stuff is about to come out
of my body
so am I going to eat open right now
[Music]
you guys can go ahead and dig in this is
a traditional Taiwanese appetizers I
don't know if you guys have ever tried
what's it called it's bean curd uh
seaweed
this first anyone Taiwanese
okay
okay we open the hole we put the cream
cheese inside and we dip in with the hot
sauce
[Music]
with the garlic garlic and and this is a
solid paste sauce open the hook okay
thank you guys like that do you want to
eat too you can sit down come on
this is the sticky toffee yeah actually
stinks oh yeah
any questions I can tell you okay
don't eat it yet
[Music]
you really don't smell it at all I do
but it smells delicious and appetizing
no it doesn't
so after years of like growing up with
it it just smells delectable to you can
I can I be honest with you guys my
grandpa first brought this out I was
like this thing smells like [ __ ] of
course
that what can I be honest with you guys
just say it later on as I got older I
think my DNA took over what do I do I do
that yeah bro this is like one of my
favorites just do the whole thing at
once through your nose let's go boys
is that it touch your shoes
how is it it's pretty good
I don't like that Bart's laughing
it's delicious tastes like it smells and
that doesn't go away
this one is the pork chop yeah
we have potato powder okay yeah
[Music]
okay let me get some of that sauce so
yeah
just like that there's a little napkin
[Laughter]
dude I can't do it because you know what
what smells like [ __ ] it smells like my
[ __ ] urologist's breath good I'm
trying to man that can do probably like
nothing all right dude but we're all
we're off but oh man
[Music]
dig in try everything
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
three
things
[Music]
so we come out we loiter with around
Boppo milfo so we can make sure our fans
remember who the real Asian YouTubers
are you know what I'm saying and that
right bar yeah [ __ ] one food
[ __ ] oh dang
dude that's what you're trying to say
right no I was trying to give it up to
the real YouTubers that really paved the
way for Asians out here good job
huh
[Laughter]
hey let me see your phone let me
subscribe to our Channel
thank you bro it's very good
this is the classic one right here this
is the brown sugar
[ __ ] classic
they feel me
this is really good though Can I taste
it yeah it's really good
you go up that bathroom I [ __ ]
destroyed it
I actually did I actually started
shoving figures a mile just to actually
destroy it yeah so I didn't just take a
number two I actually [ __ ] vomited as
well that's for you Phil
[Laughter]
and then as we leave he's like hey
that's my favorite restaurant of all
time right there
wait what the [ __ ] is there dude
of all time
all time he's like I've been to cities
all over the world it's like I've been
I've traveled I've been in my home
country he's like that's the best stuff
it's like it didn't take 25 minutes to
get here it did might as well have gone
there but no Bart's like oh we'll go
this random place on Yelp
did you expect that to be as bad as it
was I didn't because I trusted Bart when
he was like oh yeah just put sauce on it
and eat the whole thing in one bite
which I don't think Taiwanese people
really do unless they're obsessed with
it which even that is a strange thing
like I said it reminded me of when I got
circumcised the doctor that did it had a
had a breath that smelled just like that
and it took me back so yeah I might be
the only person who ever ate stinky tofu
and felt it on the tip of his dick it
tastes like it smells so like it's like
I said it smells like halitosis it
tastes like that I think Ryan would uh
but trust that point he said it smells
like his [ __ ] OB gyn's mouth or some
[ __ ] the bow was definitely amazing oh
and the the beef fall was [ __ ]
incredible
yeah
the beef noodle soup the beef soup
beef pot noodle soup with sauce beef
noodle soup
good so good order you just saying beef
like the f is just extra not FIFA the
beef noodle soup should I say false
you're welcome I'm being nice [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was pretty good it was you know
honestly it was a lot of stinkier
tasting than I remember would I get it
again probably not if I'm Gonna Keep it
a buck I was expecting Steve to kind of
react but Steve took like a champ and
also too if we roll back the tape I
don't think Anthony ate his whole piece
we will look back at the footage and
we'll corroborate that later but that's
just that's just what I think I think it
was great to see Steve be a champ and
eat it I think it was more hilarious to
see Ryan cry and nearly throw it up uh I
think it's funny like Steve said that
our took us to a spot he's never been to
but his favorite restaurant was across
the street
classic JK [ __ ] I guess you know
what I mean nobody thinks about [ __ ]
they just do [ __ ]
but I will say was that restaurant's
name again golden uh
Bistro Taipei Bistro shout out Taipei
Bistro the food is bomb and the lady
Slash the man husband wife or whatever
that was working there [ __ ] awesome
so if you want to go to a good mom pop
restaurant as good food for a great time
and great like service Taipei Bistro but
if you want to go to Bark's favorite
restaurant we'll never know we'll never
[ __ ] know
so we don't know what that tastes like I
was right there it's really good I put a
spin on it that's really that's really
good but there's really good damn cool
[Laughter]
it was so severe too he's like that's
the best phone I ever had in my [ __ ]
like [ __ ] like he's like I've been
all over he's like you guys know I've
Been Everywhere he's like that's my
favorite restaurant we're like where the
[ __ ] did we go to this other place
thanks man this new this new Adventure
Time where like different people takes
to go eat and stuff I'm really excited
for Steve's week where we eat casserole
and meatloaf no I actually know exactly
where we're wrong yeah that's why people
do that oh yeah let us know
you want to see us hang out more after
we shoot let us know in the comments
below if we should continue this JK news
adventure and until next time peace
get it
[Music]